- Thank you for joining our session today.
The best session of today, of course.
What is it that we will be
discussing today, right?
So I'm more than happy
to introduce myself.
My name is Diego, I'm part of Intel,
and I'm part of the AWS
team responsible for AIML.
And our session today and
what we thought about,
what we want actually to speak about,
and get also our customers and partners
to a little bit educate
everyone here in the room
is how do we build fast, cost
efficient, and also important,
sovereign influence
platforms using Intel CPUs.
And to do that, I think I'm
really excited to announce today
that we have a really amazing
lineup of speakers, right?
So we will be having a session
of three different use cases.
We will be having Caitlin
Anderson, who is the VP from Intel
and general manager for American sales.
We have Mickey that will
be joining us from AWS
and who is a director
for enterprise technology
specifically for gen AI
in the public sector.
We will be then having
three different customers
which will be Deloitte, Bob
Simmons with us on stage,
Amit Gupta, VP from e& Enterprise,
and at last also Renato,
who is Head of Technology from Articul8.
What can you expect from
our session today, right?
So we have 60 minutes,
we have a long time,
and I think we hope we make it as best
and as efficient as possible.
We will introduce actually
four different flows, right?
So on the one side, I
think we want to give
a little reminder Intel and AWS, right?
So what is it exact that we do?
How do we actually want to achieve
inference performance
on Intel CPUs with AWS?
And then secondly, we will deep dive
into three different use cases.
On the one side, we will be
doing an analysis actually
about how to use EC2 Intel-powered
instances for inference.
On the second side, we will
elaborate of how to develop
a sovereign inference platform
jointly with e& Enterprise.
And at last, we'll talk
about AI innovation
actually with Articul8.
And now having said all
of this, I'm super happy
to announce today actually
on stage, Caitlin,
who will be talking a little bit more
about the partnership
between Intel and AWS.
Welcome, Caitlin.
- Thank you, Diego.
Wonderful.
Well, thank you so much, and
thank you for joining us today.
We're gonna talk a little bit
just about the partnership,
and I'll start there.
Again, I've been at Intel almost 24 years,
so basically our
partnership with AWS spans
my entire career, almost 20 years.
A lot of the work that we do,
and many people don't think
about kind of the complexity
of the relationship
that we have together.
Really, from an
infrastructure perspective,
a lot of people would think about Intel
and the hardware that we build
and design and manufacture,
and obviously sell into AWS.
We have over 400 instances of
EC2 that are running Intel,
which is really... we have
this huge breadth of compute
and technology when you
talk about the hardware
and the infrastructure.
But even more important,
especially in the world of AI now,
is a lot of the optimization
we do with the software,
with the third-party
companies, like many of you
in the room, and that's what
we're gonna talk about today,
to basically optimize those instances
to run really well on Intel,
AI workloads, as well as general compute,
I should say, across all of the services
that Amazon delivers.
And then, of course, the devices,
so the breadth by which
we design our chips
and our products cover
the edge to the AIPC,
to a lot of the cloud, and of course,
data center on-prem as well.
So as we think about AWS and
the span of all the devices
and the services that they offer across
the breadth of the
ecosystem, Intel participates
in every one of those things.
So it's a really dynamic
and important partnership.
It's growing by the minute.
We have a lot that we do
together strategically
across both of our companies,
and I'm super excited
for what's ahead as well.
Let's roll the video and talk about it.
I want you to hear it from our
CEO, Lip-Bu, and Dave Brown,
who's the VP of Compute for AWS.
- AWS has a longstanding
relationship with Intel,
actually dating back to
the launch of Amazon EC2
all the way in 2006.
- Intel relationship with AWS span more
than 18 years and continue to grow.
Our collaboration runs deep.
- Today, I'm excited to talk
about our most recent launch,
AWS 8th generation Intel-based instances.
- Our latest Xeon 6 with P-Core technology
delivers reliability and
performance to cloud providers
like AWS and their customers.
- The new Intel instances
offer up to 20% performance
improvement over previous
generation Intel-based instances
across diverse workloads.
For real-world applications, we believe
the performance gains will be even higher.
- This isn't just about migrating
existing workloads to the cloud.
It is about unlocking new possibilities
through nimble and data-driven
development pipelines.
- With the 8th generation Intel instances,
AWS is adding support for
Instance Bandwidth Configuration,
or IBC, a new feature
that we launched last year
with our 8th generation
Graviton instances.
IBC will give x86
customers the flexibility
to optimize their network
and storage performance
based on their specific workload needs.
Our 8th generation custom
Intel Xeon 6 processor
CM&R instances offer new Flex variants
that have been designed
for customers who workloads
have variable compute patterns.
They offer a cost-effective alternative
to standard instances and
provide the easiest way
for customers to achieve
price performance benefits.
- The future of cloud
computing will require
even more powerful, flexible,
and efficient solutions.
And Intel is proud to be driving
that transformation alongside AWS.
- We're excited to see how
our customers will use them
to drive their businesses forward.
- Wonderful.
So thank you very much.
And also, I mentioned this
is Intel's AI strategy,
but really a little bit of
our philosophy as a company.
For those that have worked
with Intel for many years,
we have always had an open
ecosystem approach to innovation.
That's a big part of our promise.
It's a big part of actually,
we're spending a lot of money
as a company now to invest
in the x86 ecosystem
to make sure that it's strong and healthy.
And that means that we
always really kind of start
with an open ecosystem approach a lot.
And we'll talk a lot about the software
that we are developing
to deliver and contribute
to the open source community as well.
When you talk about AI.
'Cause at the end of the day,
we've been through many
cycles of innovation
and AI is certainly one.
We liken it sometimes to
the wireless innovation
when things change in the PC dramatically.
All of that required the
ecosystem to come along.
One company cannot deliver
a movement like that.
And that's what AI is.
All the entire ecosystem,
when we really have
this open approach and
not these verticalized
kind of locked in systems,
that's when innovation
will thrive and go faster and scale.
And that's what we believe
will, kind of at the beginning
stages of this when you
talk about enterprise AI.
Of course, we want it to be efficient.
We want the TCO to be very
good for your companies.
And I know that you're
facing that as you're making
your own decisions on how to
develop AI for yourselves,
but also to deploy it to your customers.
And of course, we want it to be secure.
We have a long history
in the enterprise market.
We know how to drive security
and how to deliver that for
our enterprise customers,
and that's a bedrock of what we do across
both the hardware and the software.
Okay, and then many people
may or may not know,
we've been working a lot.
We've always had a strong ISV ecosystem,
so part of that ecosystem work
that we do has been to invest
in a lot of the software
providers for many years
to develop on Intel.
But as AI has grown both on the PC
and in our data center business,
we have strengthened and
really tried to invest
a lot more time and energy and money
into enabling and
supporting our ISV customers
across to be not only
just enabled and developed
on Intel and optimized
for Intel instances,
but also to work with AWS as well.
And there's a lot of really great joint
three-way partnerships
that we have as we think
about solutions selling into the market.
So Adobe is just one example.
Integrating AI into the creative tools,
we work very closely with
Adobe on all of their use cases
and making sure that it
can run the best on Intel.
SAP is a huge customer of
ours as we think about the AI
solutions that they're
delivering to market.
And Arqit may be one
you know or don't know,
but really quantum safe encryption,
some a lot in security.
And these are just a few
examples of companies
where we've been partnering
to create programs
through our channel programs to make sure
that they can get access
to tools and technology,
but also to programs and marketing
so they can scale their efforts.
And many of these are also AWS customers.
So a lot of work in the ISV ecosystem.
You're gonna hear from a
few of them today as well.
And so we can bring a little
of those stories to life.
And then lastly, I know it probably sounds
really convenient that we would say CPUs
can be used for AI because
we obviously develop CPUs.
But really at the end of the day,
and I've been tracking this,
I started out really
kind of thinking about
the AIPC space and moving
over into data center as well.
You know, the AI revolution right now
has been heavy on training.
There's a lot of a handful of companies
really developing these amazing models,
training and doing some
of this hardcore AI work
to build the foundation.
But we are at this point
now where enterprise scale
really hasn't happened yet.
Enterprise AI in the way that I think
that we all envisioned for the future.
And it's just beginning.
And a lot of that is gonna
be on inference workloads.
When you think about
the next kind of phase
or chapter of AI, we believe a few things.
We believe that inference workloads
will definitely be growing
at a significant rate.
We certainly believe that agentic AI
is gonna be a really
big piece of the theme
of the next couple of years.
And that we also believe that it will run
across a variety of compute.
That it's not just a GPU workload
at the end of the day.
That you're gonna need all
sorts of types of hardware
to drive the right TCO and ROI to run
these inference workloads.
And there is a lot of great examples
of how inference workloads
can run best on Xeon.
And we've just launched
our Xeon 6 processor,
which is our latest generation.
And we'll show you
actually how you can run
a very simple inference
workload directly on Xeon.
I know I can say that,
but we wanted to show you
so you have the visual.
So just behind me, this is just an example
of just a simple chat kind of use case
where they're searching for information.
And this is all running directly on Xeon.
If we go back...
I think it's a video.
Nope.
Well, it is running a
video in the background,
but we'll have to keep moving there.
But simply, I think from
a lot of the use cases
that you're thinking
about for your company,
we're gonna talk to you
about how they can run
on Xeon as well.
And for that, I wanted
to invite Miki on stage
from AWS to share a little
bit of his perspective
on the partnership.
Welcome.
- Thank you, Caitlin.
- Thank you.
- The Intel and AWS partnership
has been strong since 2006.
And we've been collaborating to develop
transformative technology and innovation
that supports our customers'
enterprise workloads.
AWS has launched 400-plus
Intel-based instances
to serve the diverse
needs of its customers
across all of its regions.
And this partnership continues
to grow and to scale.
Back in September 2024,
we signed a collaborative multi-billion,
multi-year strategic agreement
to invest in chip-making.
And that partnership
is delivering results.
I'm very excited to talk
about the custom Xeon 6
on Intel 3 that is now generally available
on Amazon EC2 8i instances.
This is across the C, the R,
and the M family of instances.
And I really want to talk about the fact
that this is custom.
There is great engineering collaboration
that's gone into developing a purposeful,
purpose-built chip that allows
us to bring unique advantages
to our customers, giving
them the highest performance
as well as the fastest memory bandwidth
and delivering value to them.
Notably, this is 20% faster
from a compute performance perspective.
And when it comes to inferencing-based
recommendation models, it's
showing 40% better performance
to the older generations.
This is truly fascinating.
We have the fastest Intel chip
on the cloud running in AWS.
But I also wanna talk about
how there are AI capabilities
and acceleration capabilities
in this new technology.
The AMX Xeon 6 Intel chip uses
advanced matrix extension.
And what this does is it
allows you to do optimization
of the matrix multiplication
that provides much,
much faster inferencing and
much, much faster training
and it also opens up the array,
a wide array of workloads
through which inferencing can be done.
And this really opens up the business
to a large set of industries.
It leads to faster training
and faster inferencing
that I mentioned, but it
also helps conserve energy
and scales beautifully.
Now, what we have done
with this EC2-8i instance
is that we have introduced it
over these different families
which are the M, the
C, and the R families.
But as you saw in Dave Brown's video,
we also have the flex
option that's available.
And with this flex option,
you can have customers
match the pricing to their demand.
So another thing that we've done
is that we've launched these in the US
and the Spain region
and we are now working
on launching these to
additional AWS regions as well.
A great example of our
collaboration with Intel
is what Technology
Innovation Institute has done
in UAE by using this technology to develop
their Falcon large language model.
We also have many other
partners and customers
that are benefiting
from these technologies.
Next, to hear stories
of one of our partners
who've done fascinating work in this area,
I would like to invite
Bob Simmons from Deloitte
to the stage.
Bob.
- Thanks.
Hi, my name's Bob Simmons from Deloitte.
I'm in the government and
public service sector.
So what I'm here to
talk about is some work
that we've been doing
with Intel on running
LLMs and SLMs on a CPU.
So the Deloitte AI
strategy really comes down
to we invest heavily
into our practitioners,
training them, and heavily into
developing new capabilities,
which this is gonna be one of.
What we're looking at from
two different perspectives
is how can AI win in the market
and then how can clients win with AI?
So what does the market want?
They want a cost efficient
way of doing inferencing.
They need to be able to scale.
So most of the projects
don't deliver on the ROI,
whether it be cost savings,
whether it be reduction
in labor, whether it be an
increased customer satisfaction.
When it goes into a prototype,
it doesn't go into production.
And from production,
sometimes it's hard to scale,
especially if you're looking
at trying to use GPUs
and there's not enough out there.
Maybe you don't have the
funds to cover a GPU 24-7,
but you can a CPU.
So what we're looking
at is running on a CPU
and being able to reduce
the cost and able to scale.
So how can the clients win with AI?
One way is to use CPUs with
SLMs and compressed LLMs,
and we'll get into that in a little bit.
And most clients have
a large infrastructure
of CPU-based EC2s, which
makes it easier to scale.
It decreases the cost by about 50%,
50% plus if you're looking at the OEM,
excuse me, the O&M.
And then it enables scaling
and also increases security.
Now, what I mean by increases security
is in the GPS, they will
have a full-up AWS cloud
on the unclassified government network.
They have a full-up AWS
cloud on the secret network
and a full-up AWS cloud
on the top secret network.
Three full clouds not
connected to the internet.
So the security is when you're on-premise,
you can have different
organizations that don't want
to share data within the same agency,
thinks of human resources and benefits.
I don't wanna send PHI
to the overall ChatGPT
that the agency uses.
If I'm in contracts, I don't
wanna send Deloitte rates
to ChatGPT to say fill
out this form for me.
So what this makes possible
is, within your own VPC,
to have your own gen AI to do
your work that never leaves.
And for a lot of my customers,
that's top priority.
On this, the current
landscape is AI data centers
are estimated to really grow.
I think they've already talked about this,
but it's growing fast and
GPUs aren't out there,
at least for my client, getting the GPUs
onto their networks.
So that's a problem.
They have a large infrastructure
of EC2s, TPU-based.
So going down to CPUs
such as the Intel Xeon,
it offers a cheaper localized
alternative to GPUs, alright?
For the GPUs, costs are surging because
of the high demand for them.
There's massive large
language models on GPUs.
There's a lot of times
overkill for what you need,
but that may be the only
thing that's available.
The CPU-powered models
offer a budget-friendly way
to a broader adoption,
and what I'm gonna say,
democratizing it across the agencies.
So going forward, the small
language model we're seeing
is like 10 billion parameters or less.
The model compression tools,
such as the Intel's OpenVINO,
and this is kind of crucial,
and some new technologies
for compression, which
can compress models down
without losing much
accuracy, and it helps expand
the use cases that you can automate.
Alright, so where are we on this?
So we are working with the Intel Alliance.
We're testing out running
models on GPUs and CPUs.
We had a phase one where we
were running an LLM and an SLM,
both on GPUs and CPUs, and
looking at their performance.
And then we're saying,
okay, we found a company
that does compression in a way,
they call it quantum-inspired compression,
that allows them to compress it down,
say a 70 billion model or
larger, to fit on a CPU,
and we wanted to know what
was the decrease in accuracy.
That's phase two.
And then we went to a
phase three when we said,
okay, that compressed model didn't have
a large enough context window.
So when we're running it
from the GPU to the CPU
on phase one, of course we saw,
and we got SLMs to work uncompressed,
but not the LLMs, just too large, right?
But you can get a 56% reduction
in O&M infrastructure costs,
as I mentioned earlier.
And it outperformed in
terms of efficiency,
not necessarily speed, but
when you're looking at energy
and cost and availability for
scaling, it outperformed it.
On phase two, the compressed
models run almost twice
as fast as the uncompressed
models, which also increased,
so if you don't want to buy more hardware,
you can license a compressed
model and do twice the work.
We went to phase 3A, and
we're on the phase two
on this chat bot, we were
getting 71.3% accuracy
and the client wanted 75%.
We went from just a larger
context window to 80.7%,
and note that the
uncompressed model had 81.7%,
so we lost 1%, which was...
I think it was like a...
so you're keeping like
98.5% of the accuracy
of the uncompressed model.
We saw this and said,
alright, we've now shown
that you can run large language models
on CPUs and small language models,
and that you can run them faster,
and going on to the next slide, actually.
So on the GPUs, Amazon, we
were using Amazon EC2 8i's.
This is the Xeon 4, and then
the monthly cost for the GPU
and the monthly cost for the CPU,
you're looking at about
a 56% reduction in cost.
What you're seeing on the
lower left and the lower right
is the tokens per second on the left,
and then the latency on the right.
The OpenVINO model server
is optimized for the Xeon.
So we're using a Xeon that has 48 CPUs.
When it loads it, it actually
does parallel processing
between those CPUs, so
on the bottom scale,
you'll see one user,
two users going on up.
These are simultaneous users,
and you see the CPU is flat.
And actually, when you
get up to a certain point,
the CPU outperforms the
GPUs, but then the latency
is getting up there.
And the tokens per
second, you can also see
where it's flat on the tokens per second,
and then finally right around 40,
it starts to drop off.
So this also depends on your use case.
If you're not really time-dependent,
you can use this, or
a GPU if you're really
time-dependent and need speed.
Alright, the target use
case areas for the SLM
is basically when we need security,
when we need infrastructure for scaling,
when we need to be on-premise,
where CPUs are prevalent and
GPUs aren't as prevalent.
Multi-dentric use cases,
one of the next phases
we're gonna be doing is
a more complex use case
where there's gonna be
three different agents
running on an EC2, CPU-based EC2,
and that works very well, actually.
And then on-edge devices,
say satellites, drones.
Let's say you're in manufacturing
and you want LLM out on
the manufacturing floor
on different machines.
So these are the use
cases we're looking at.
So one of the use cases
we're gonna be doing next
is say you have a sensitive document.
I'm just gonna call it,
it's an intelligence report, right?
If we want to send that to some allies,
we've got to remove some information.
So one agent's gonna find the information
and then show it to the Intel analyst
and say, is this correct?
Then it's gonna remove the information
and rewrite it as a second
agent and then show it
to the analyst and say, is this right?
And then it's gonna go back
and it's gonna reclassify
the document based off of what
information it pulled out.
So this is just a multi-agentic
system doing a more complex,
now granted this is gonna be using
a 70 billion parameter
that's been compressed down
to fit on a 8i instance.
Alright, well actually,
I need to hand this off.
- Okay, so we talked a little
bit about... thank you, Bob.
What I love about this is
it's nice to have partners
like Deloitte who are
really coming alongside
to bring these use cases to life to see
how they come to fruition
with real customers.
I said that I'll talk a
little bit about software too.
Many people don't know
that we have thousands
of software engineers at
Intel and we've been working
in this ecosystem for many years.
But we talked about this open approach.
Certainly with any large
framework providers,
any of the large language model providers,
we're working with all of them.
For ourselves, we wanna make sure
as any version drops of any
of these models as well,
we have a very short turnaround
that they're up and running on Intel.
So that's been really successful
and we're gonna continue this work.
There's a depth of those relationships
that it's quite strong.
We also have our own software.
We talked about oneAPI.
That really is optimized for Intel
and it's available to all of you.
We've been actually working with oneAPI
in our edge business for many, many years
across all the verticals.
We can talk about optimizing.
That's where that started.
But it's expanded dramatically with AI.
So oneAPI is really a great tool.
Encourage you all to take a look at that.
And then of course, we have open standards
and protocols that we also
develop within the ecosystem.
So UCIe, CXL is some of those as well.
So a lot of work in terms
of how we contribute
to this open ecosystem software approach,
both with companies and also
our own contributions as well.
And then lastly, we actually
just announced Intel AI
for Enterprise Inference.
Let's try to say that a couple times fast.
But really the intent there is simple,
easy to use software deployment
for this inference workload
that we've been discussing.
The beauty of having the AWS instance
in the cloud is that
this is just available
when you choose the EC2 AI instance.
- You get this software as well
as part of that experience.
But really, it goes all
the way down the stack
to really think about how you can leverage
and optimize for inference
workloads on Intel.
And we're gonna continue to build on this
and continue that development.
So, as an example of someone that's using
or used this software, I
wanted to invite Amit up
from e& to talk about a
little bit of how he used
this software for development for the UAE.
So, welcome Amit.
- Thank you, Caitlin, for
the kind introduction.
Hi, I'm Amit Gupta, I'm
the VP for e& Enterprise.
I lead the data and AI practice for Asia,
Middle East, Africa, and Europe.
And today I'm going to talk
about how we are collaborating
with Intel to build the
enterprise AI inference stack
and how we are uniquely solving a problem
whereby we create something which is open,
transparent, cost effective, and sovereign
for our UAE customers.
But before that, let me talk a little bit
about what we offer as
e& data and AI practice.
So, we offer a full stack
practice whereby we are
providing AI connectivity,
AI infrastructure,
AI solutions and services,
but also AI devices.
So, we provide the full stack.
We've already delivered a
lot of these AI solutions,
more than 200 plus AI
cases and 200 use cases
across sectors and industries.
We are tech and platform agnostic,
which means we work across AI
and data platforms as
well as hyperscalers.
We have a large team of AI
resources located globally.
And we have developed
in-house AI accelerators
that give value within
weeks instead of months.
And last but not the least, we
also have our own AI Academy
where we train practitioners
and a lot of other leaders on AI.
We have our latest flagship program,
the Chief AI Officer Program,
which we are running very successfully.
Okay, so I'm sure all of you have seen
some of these statistics.
The key point here is inference
market is going to grow.
The AI inference market is
gonna grow exponentially.
You know, you can see that
from 100 billion this year
to more than 250 billion
in the next five years.
And through 2028, what we have seen
is the cost of AI
inference is at least 70%
of the total model
lifetime, which is far more
than the training costs
that are required to do
to train a model.
So as you can see, the inferencing costs
are very, very high.
And some of these stats
talk about that at least 50%
of gen AI projects will
overrun the budgeted costs,
as per Gartner.
Now, how do we build this solution?
Now, the question is, how do we build
the inference AI platform
to meet the customer needs?
Before that, let's address
some of the challenges.
And I'm sure most of you in this room
are also facing these
challenges in your enterprises.
The first one is about costs.
Organizations implementing
AI at enterprise scale today
face a lot of cost constraints,
often leading to more than 300 to 500%
exceeding whatever we had planned.
The second is about
infrastructure management.
And if you know that AI workloads
today have unprecedented
infrastructure demands,
and our traditional
IT systems cannot handle that.
Not only that, they also have
a lot of parallel processing,
as you know, with all the kind
of heterogeneous requirements
like CPUs, GPUs, TPUs, and
AI chips working in tandem.
And lastly, data sovereignty.
We are building AI for UAE from UAE,
which means all our data has
to reside within the country,
which is cost effective,
which doesn't go out,
which is generated,
protected, and preserved
within the country and
meets the local norms.
So how do we tackle
these three challenges?
So it is through our solution
that we call it SLM in a Box,
or Small Language Model in a Box.
And more precisely, we are
leveraging both Intel AI
for enterprise inference and
Intel AI X-rated instances
to power our sovereign
inference as a service platform.
And our goal is twofold.
One is, of course, keeping
everything in the region,
which means that we are
looking to build a solution
which is independent from
all other AWS regions,
meaning that we wanted to
serve only our UAE customers
through the UAE AWS region.
Second is about being
open and cost effective.
So we wanted to address
sovereignty through automation,
through cost, through security,
and through transparency.
And to do so, we are
using Intel 7AI instances
as inference at point, which
is allowing our customers
to not only build use
cases over the platform,
but also offer use cases
which are ready to made
or ready to deploy.
Okay.
Maybe we can go a little
bit more into deep dive
how our solution works.
And as Caitlin mentioned
in the introduction,
the users of GPUs is only for
inference is a myth, right?
We have come ourselves to a conclusion
that when running specifically
small language models,
models with below 10 billion parameters,
Intel instances are a perfect fit.
And it's great to see a
variety of partnerships
in UAE as Mickey also
mentioned about how TII built
through the Falcon model, right?
Now let's deep dive a little
bit more into the solution,
specifically two takeaways
that I want to highlight.
One is we win with open.
As you can see on the right hand side,
our architecture is only
leveraging open source components.
Not only this, it's also helping
in becoming cost effective.
We are advancing using what the
community is building today,
so it remains cost effective.
Two is about flexibility.
That's one thing I really wanted
to point out is flexibility.
So in today's world where
AI is changing everything
so quickly, there's so many
new models getting built in,
this platform helps you choose
the model that you want.
And it can be deployed out of box.
So that's one of the
key advantages of this.
Okay, just to bring it home now,
I think most of the slides
have spoken about the benefits
that we have received, but
let me summarize it for you.
One, it reduces complexity,
which means introducing
a full automated solution.
Two, it's quick time to value
with automated deployment
and management of AI and LLM models.
Three, it's scalable with
embedded auto scaling.
Four, we are talking about
being cost effective,
which is very, very critical
in the overall scheme of things.
We are leveraging Intel
CPUs as inference at point.
Five, it's secure by design.
We are deploying it with
built-in authentication and APIs.
And lastly, it's sovereign by design.
We are deploying it only
for our UAE customers,
leveraging UAE region only, and owing
to our inference stack, infrastructure,
orchestration, everything is happening
in the AWS region in UAE.
So that's it from my side.
Thank you very much, and
over to you, Caitlin.
- Okay, we are just bringing it home here.
So the last, we talked a lot, obviously,
about our AWS partnership.
We talked about customers
that are leveraging
inference workloads on Xeon.
I'm gonna shift a little
bit to a new company
called Articul8, and really,
it's an amazing company.
It actually started at Intel,
and we kind of spun it off.
It was a great startup story,
but I'm really impressed
with their use case.
I'm impressed with their platform.
It's a lot more about using your data,
enterprise data and
insights inside your company
to unlock those insights.
I have Renato here to tell
us more about Articul8,
so welcome onto the stage.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Caitlin.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Renato Nascimento, head
of technology at Articul8.
Thrilled to be here talking
about what we are building at Articul8.
So Articul8 is a platform
that's a smart layer
that helps enterprise to convert complex,
unstructured, or structured data
into hyper-personalized outcomes,
as you can see here on the right.
On this vertical integrated platform,
we help you to run across
different agents and models.
So it's a vertical integrated
platform that works
either on your own
premise or can be deployed
on your own VPC within your AWS account.
So at left, as your data
comes into your platform,
that data gets break
down into its components,
and that components runs through our model
mesh in-house orchestrator that will use
a library of different models,
a combination between traditional
machine learning models,
small language models, and
also large language models
to understand your data,
and most important,
domain-specific models and
also task-specific models,
and we'll talk a little bit
more about that later on.
That gets break down and understood
where we'll build a knowledge graph,
and this knowledge graph here
is a little bit different
than what is done out there.
We also augmented the
content from your data
using the domain specificity
from your own enterprise,
creating and help you to see connections
that are not directly
implied on the data as well.
So what are the key
differentiations of our platform?
One is our intelligent model routing,
where we built an in-house
model orchestrator
that helps you at runtime
autonomously decide
which agent or model
will be used for the task
that you're trying to achieve at hand.
We do that by evaluating
every single of those models,
agents across the tasks that are important
for your use case, and I'll
show a couple examples as well.
All of that with a platform
that gives you observability.
You can audit every single
decision that those actions
are taking on your behalf
on the platform as well,
and that can be run in scales.
We have use cases that have been run
with hundreds of thousands of files,
generating knowledge graphs with millions
of entities running in production.
And more importantly, our platform comes
with a combination of, in the
library, of domain-specific
and task-specific models that helps you
to achieve a complex use case.
And I brought here an
example to help you visualize
why domain-specific models
are important, right?
If you're trying to do
something very specific
or a use case, the general
purpose models out there,
they might fall short
of achieving your goal.
In this example here, we have an image.
This image is a grid, is a
testing system for power cables.
And if you send that to,
for instance, in this case,
to cloud, you see that the
image gets poorly classified.
And then if you use one of
our domain-specific models,
in this case, it's a
domain-specific model,
that one can not only understand
what this image is about,
but also all the minutiae
and details underlying
of that image as well.
So if you have an expert use case,
that data might not be
out there on the public,
or even if your data is
out there in the public,
you might have to heavily prompt engineer
general purpose models
to achieve that goal,
and might be rule-based,
which might also fall short
in corner use cases.
Also, we brought here,
that was an example,
but we also don't believe
in benchmarks internally
with Articul8 what we do as part
of a model orchestrator as well.
We test every single model in agents
that are part of our platform across
a different variety of dimensions.
On this example here, we have
our domain-specific model
being tested across 10
different domains, sorry,
dimensions, created by
experts of the area.
Each of those tasks
contain very curated tasks
that those experts on that
domain want's to achieve,
and on this spider plot, closer to 100%
means how accurate you are on that task.
Here we can see, across
all these 10 domains,
our domain-specific model overperforms
with more than 25% accuracy than ever
other model available there,
either private models,
state-of-the-art, like GPT-5,
or even large open-source models as well.
Not only that, towards running
optimized inference costs
as well, this model is
also a fraction of the size
of every other model there, too.
So you can not only achieve
better results across
different tasks that are specialized,
but also reduce your
overall cost of inference.
And I brought one example here
with the domain-expert model,
but we have data and experiments like that
for all of domain-specific
models out there.
For instance, semiconductor manufacturing,
supply chain, financial services as well.
And that's all embedded and
imbedded on our platform.
It comes as we deploy
the platform as well.
So our platform also brings
with it all the optimizations
and expertise the team
has built over the years,
helping optimize what model
works best with what hardware.
So we have a library of models
from all different sides,
so we need to understand at
the real time which model,
which hardware is gonna
be used to execute that,
either for the small ones
that will be CPU-optimized,
or even from very large
general-purpose models
as well that will run on GPU.
We also are AWS partners,
certified AI on the AI competency.
That means we have a very
tried-and-true solution
that deploys into AWS,
optimizing the resources,
and follow all the best
practices there as well.
And just to close out,
I also wanna talk about
how you can start to see our products.
So our product is a subscription,
either subscribe to our software,
or you can subscribe to our
managed solution as well
if you wanna start before
you get your own deployment
on your own AWS account or your own VPC.
But also, we have our
domain-specific models
and agents available
into the AWS Marketplace
for you to try it.
I'm also proud to announce that today,
not today, this week, we
are launching a new agent
on AWS Marketplace that
does table understanding.
And with that agent, you
can upload very complex
unstructured files that have
data on the type of tables,
either images or normal
table, it doesn't matter.
That agent will understand that table
and send that back to
you, and you only pay
the user's cost cents.
So it's very easy to start using us,
either through our AWS
Marketplace offering
or getting directed with us
using our managed solution as well.
If you want to know more about us,
please check out our website, articul8.ai,
and thank you very much.
Back to you, Caitlin.
- Okay, thank you.
Thank you, Renato.
Okay, we will wrap it up.
So thank you so much
for being with us today.
Just a few key takeaways to take with you.
Certainly, check out the EC2-8i instance
with our Xeon 6.
We know now, after this session,
that you can use these for this instance,
not only for your inference workloads,
but obviously general compute as well.
We will lead and continue
to lead with an open
and trusted AI approach.
We will invest in the ecosystem.
We'd love to partner as well when we talk
about this third part.
If you're a software
provider, you wanna be part
of some of the programs,
if you have interest
in how to get involved,
we'd love to talk to you
after the session in the hall as well.
And then, of course, the more you can do,
there's an Intel booth
in the showcase as well.
We have roundtables on different topics
throughout the next couple of days,
and you're welcome to meet the team
and contact us just through this QR code.
So thank you so much for taking your time
and investing in this
session, and we appreciate it.
Have a great day.
(audience applauds)